i am here
to fight for
for this country for our values
our european values
it is very easy to sit on the couch and
say that you know
we are europe yeah
we have this
you know democracy
and pluralism
and freedom of uh religion yeah
but we are sitting on the couches right
so
i do believe that uh russian aggression
and war
is evil
and um you know plato said that
the worst evil of all is ignorance
so who are you here with what what other
nationalities are you here with
how do you all get together uh we have
uh different people from very very
different places from uh
from uh australia to
from australia to
austria to israel to lithuania to
denmark to
well i mean this is united nations to
united nations
so and have you seen action already
how bad was it
you saw the news you knew the news so
yeah
did you lose people uh we were
you were lucky not to
how many of you at a time are in groups
i can't say yeah
and are you going back are you leaving
now has it put you on yeah
at this moment we we are grouping and we
will
go back in
it's everywhere in you can't still it's
over it's
it's it it's as as a famous song says it
ain't over till it's over do you have
any british people with you
uh actually yeah
ex-military what do you know
and why and why are they here that i
mean same same reason same reason
same reason
and will you stay even though it clearly
is ugly and as you say people are dying
every day residential buildings being
hit every day are you determined to stay
80 years ago only eight years ago six
million jews were butchered you know why
not because of someone came to kill them
you know oh hitler was a bad boy and he
killed everyone no
this is we indifferent people ignorant
people staring from our windows
we said back then that oh those jews are
they are killing those jews
it's the same story
come from your couches
get up your bottom
do something about it if you have a
combat experience combat not military
combat experience go and fight
if you don't
there are
millions ways
million ways
to help ukraine
just don't be ignorant that that that
that was killing
those people here